I understand that societal norms are
changing it's generally frowned upon to
twist a four year old so we're gonna get
into the top five creepiest examples of
Joe vine and by the way this is not a
new thing for Republicans okay and I
think we can bring up an overlay here of
all the sources that talked about floors
oh wow um if you search at ladders
credit com we vote five years ago about
the top five creepiest moments for doing
so Republicans conservatives have known
about was just any time it was ignored
no one cared about it there were too
busy accusing Brett Kavanaugh of running
quaalude rape gangs so he did to be fair
he did just issue a statement on Twitter
not long before taking the show we said
I realized that social norms are
changing but I hear you hold on a second
are they really changing that much
so before you to the top five examples
for context here's a dramatization of
exactly how Vice President Joe Biden
allegedly behaved hello miss Flores oh
and for legal liability purposes I
couldn't use an actual woman in this
reenactment what's that perfume
[Music]
[Laughter]
we spared no expense
I think I'm not saying if you guys are
rapists I don't think that's the case so
I don't want this to be inconsistent but
I am saying that he behaves in a creepy
enough way that it would make most women
their spouses their parents very
uncomfortable unless you think that
we're making this up we have video
evidence of all this so a creepy moment
number five this is it's tough to pick a
sequence but we'll just start with this
ash Carter's wife here you go as well
for their trust and confidence got a lot
of thanks to give out that's first and
foremost to my perfect my wife
hold her to your side first off look at
she's looking away when he realizes the
cameras are on him that's so creepy
he knows the cameras are on him your
husband's distracted imagine no
conservative would act that with a
camera on them because of the torch in
pitchfork mob oh he knows that no one
was gonna call him on this again doesn't
mean he's a rapist doesn't mean that
sexual assault probably made it very
uncomfortable by the way hit the
notification bell join at DeLaughter
with better calm slash mullet if you
haven't already got the daily show in
the entire outline of subscribe on
iTunes leave us a rating in it bookmark
this page because subscriptions don't
really mean a whole lot anymore anyway
okay we'll move our website there's four
more clips creepy moment numbers of an
alert again these have been hard to it
could have been a hundred yeah Senator
Chris Coons let's just go senator Chris
Coons daughter he go
watch the fault she literally Bob's her
head like a cockatiel just she's so I'm
she's only 13 oh my gosh but it sounds
like she was warned - she knew when he
came in like she actually started
pulling away the moment he touched it
it looks to me like she was
uncomfortable what he said before he
kissed her he was mouthing something I'm
thinking you should be saying and then
he goes so here's the thing she was
ready for the kiss yeah it wasn't like a
jerk it was a you would call it in
boxing a bob and weave you know what's
like okay the punch just kind of slips
Fred she just cradled it she's just
great and I never really got to look for
the girl I was dating which means she
must have been tipped off in this case
she must have known what was that yes
well I think when you add up the
totality of the gharana
at least one dad should kick his ass
well of course yes so here you go here's
another here's a creepy moment number
three and then we kind of to pick one
because he's done this multiple times
fondling little girls chests
watching the girl reacts watch when she
pulls wet his hand drifts over she pulls
away yeah he does it again now I don't
know if it's too I don't know if it's
deliberate but at a certain point
ignorance is not a defense and here's
the thing
picture picture if that happened I don't
any any kind of a gathering baptism I
don't know awake some kind of a funeral
right you're out in a family event and
something like that happened yeah it
would be the sole point of conversation
at dinner that night did you see what
Uncle Joe did yeah I know he's touching
that teenagers it would be it would be
the dinner table conversation because of
how creepy it is my point I don't I
don't know if any crime was committed
here I certainly don't think it
constitutes rape but isn't it creepy
enough especially if we're going to use
the standard from today's left and I
don't even think you need to use their
standard I think you need to use the
standard of common decency
don't touch little girls nipples just
just remember Stephen that standards
have changed over the last few years I
understand that societal norms are
changing it's generally frowned upon to
twist a four year old don't try to put
him back into that time frame Minnie
Minnie oh just a few years ago sorry
yeah everyone's uptight about it now
just cuz I give some guy's wife a hickey
and his Senate hearing I mean just
really it's enough all right creepy
moment number two again we're just let's
go with this what senator Jim Risch his
daughter
[Music]
look at your home okay
you ever see the movie The Lovely Bones
no where's the pedophile guys Oh Bri
polite I'm showing Roy's be polite if
that's the kind of thing when you watch
these creepy films where someone
shouldn't be touching a kid in a way
that they're touching them they brush
the hair back like that it isn't right
it is intensely uncomfortable by the way
he singles out the young girl - yeah
this is something you'll notice as a
trend and the dad by the way joking
about standing too close that shows that
they're already uneasy about the
situation well you can see what this is
not only how they react but you can see
how they kind of try to preempt this
because they know it's coming it's well
known that this is how Joe Biden acts
around women both young and old
okay so creepy mama this one to me
deserve a number one spot is it is it
Kelly is it a OD a OD I don't know how
to pronounce it MA sometimes I realize I
only read the names I don't say them out
loud okay his daughter and here's why
because this one goes on for so long
that we actually had to put it in
fast-forward and put a creepy timer up
on the board
otherwise I'm take the whole show here
you go
no boys until you're 32 now look look
look he puts his hands in it let you
know mouth
he's fishhooking her oh he's great he's
now he goes back from minute 9 goes back
he's grabbing her head she's old she's
holding her face like this look it's the
leather strap in the Green Mile ooh back
to the chair it is so creepy and but no
serious guys until you're 31 who looks
at a little girl and thinks about dating
huh then what it's sad by the way again
pieces you know what there's a boy there
yes attention it's like a reverse
Michael Jackson's yeah it's very least
he's not gay nothing no if you were like
a grandfatherly figure uncle figure who
just really liked kids you'd expect
there to be a friendly interaction and
boys well and here that would also be a
way to look it go okay how does he
interact with young men there are some
guys and this is the thing I'm talking
about I know everyone has family members
you have family Murr so maybe kiss
people on the cheek kiss people on the
lips depending what your what your your
lineage is I had know a lot of Italian
people are very affectionate yeah but
Joe bye max this
way with other professionals or complete
strangers this is what matters here and
you would be able to see a pattern if
you'd see with little boys hey how you
doing you know kind of pop them on the
chin and grab their shoulders give them
a bear hug but you don't see that you
see him gravitate toward the women
toward the little girls sniff them touch
their bosoms it is unbelievable to me
that what some people are calling about
great and the left others are extending
him but here's in contrast to Cavanaugh
were the left with a completely united
despite no real evidence that they
wanted to ruin the guy's career on the
right again we were trying to be as
consistent as possible here we're all
saying that his behaviors inappropriate
creepy enough that would warrant a
father husband spouse boyfriend kicking
an ass that's now here's the big
difference though and not only
difference between how they treated
Kavanagh right they accused him of
quaalude gang rape Yeah right along with
was a four to basically accuse him of
also trying to rape her in a place that
could not be bear verified at a time
that wasn't consistent with people who
weren't even there kind of like Joe
Biden when he talked about things on the
campaign trail I'll go to Amy's diner
you've never been there it doesn't exist
anymore hasn't been there for 30 years
and you never spoke with the Pope he's
make stuff up he makes stuff that he's
just you know this just happens and I
don't think it's deliberately lying so
you don't think is any malice here but
the big difference between what Joe
Biden is done
not nearly as egregious as rape okay
right not nearly as severe as the
accusations against Brett Kavanaugh the
difference is Joe Biden did it and he
still does it so people get to a hole a
second huh are you saying it's as bad to
fawned a little young girl's chest that
just makes you are you saying that's as
bad as gang rape no well then you'd have
to say Cavanaugh's worse no because
there's no proof what matters more is
the person who did it is the person
guilty and as it relates to deserving at
least a fun ass-kicking from a dad Joe
Biden is guilty believe your lyin eyes
okay if you liked this video you know
you watch videos on YouTube a fiber
Jimmy Kimmel if I were Stephen Colbert
or Trevor Noah I would tell you to
subscribe but I have no corporate
overlords who demand that I do this
demeaning promo
I do the demeaning chroma because I
to subscriber hit the notification bell
because I need you I need you please do
it